you can really make an argument that
there's no need to look at news there's
no there's no news there's an addictive
like uh like a masochistic addictive
just adrenaline mindfulness i don't
wanna feel bad listen i don't wanna feel
bad i'll do my best to live a good life
and and take care of people in my own
circle remember how like it used to be
if you watched news or read the
newspaper you were smarter than everyone
else
this is you're inside your brain dude
this is you are revealing yourself yo i
mean i've never ever even attempted to
pretend i was the smartest person in a
room with me it's never even crossed my
mind
to even attempt to say a big word i know
i'm going to say it wrong
i know my level of education and it's
technically seventh grade
i skipped eighth grade and then i went
to a high school that was for juveniles
where they just jerked off on us i swear
to god i got the lessons were life
lessons they were very sticky
i know how to get out of a sticky i
learned a duck let's just say my teacher
taught me to duck and then when you get
on your knees to suck yes guys listen if
you want to get a d you're going to have
to why do i feel like you went to the
school in dangerous minds i listen i
love that you think someone was there to
help it was uh we had we had things dots
on our hands the whole time like oh we
need you wait so let me ask you because
your brain is wildly fast and i feel
like sometimes people that are like so
naturally smart and have such quick
processing speed you get bored so
fucking easily like you either did
really well in school or really offline
i just wasn't interested in school it's
like i liked math math felt good like i
liked the idea of like uh
the problem-solving aspect of math it
seemed really cool that they were just
like answers there was like that it
could work yeah i liked that yes exactly
math is the truth and i really enjoyed
that but
i never like i would like not be paying
attention and then i'd be like behind i
wouldn't remember what they were saying
so i would miss the lesson and then my
dad told me recently he's like mr jones
your fifth grade teacher or your sixth
grade teacher said that you were
you're really i have a talent in math
you just if you just focused on it you
could really go far and i was like dad
why are you telling me this at 37
but like you never told me that
i mean thank god i'd be like a fucking
little i'd be like an engineer right
by the way yeah dad you're not so good
at math because you decided to tell me
this 20 years after i needed to hear
your dad
my dad is making me laugh i called him
rachel and i was like dad i think i'm
undiagnosed dyslexic and he goes annie
who gives a shit at this point i was
like that is such a good point i'm not
gonna what am i gonna start reading
bonnie mcfarland's book has been sitting
on my i look at it every day doug
stanhope i just i'm like literally
i'm manic from hanging out with doug
stanton for two three days he's the
number one yeah he's so funny his his
hour is like crazy doug stanhope is just
one of those comedians if you don't know
who he is look him up he's just like
for comedians like the same way a tell
you know stan hope is every comedian i
feel like favorite comedian now i feel
like he's now our like carlin or our
like lenny bruce he's fucking amazing
you know what i've been thinking a lot
about um
how you know how like people be like
back in our day you know like the older
comedians will be like back in our day
like comedy we really had to like dig
for it and then but it's like you look
back on the stuff and it's like because
we live now i'm looking at their stuff
like it's so hacky
yeah i will like look at the grates and
i'll be like i've heard that a million
times it's just because people have been
imitating them do you know what i mean
we get it black people and white people
i know that's so much well george carl
and i watch it and i'm like
that's a good point
yeah but i i guess back then that was
shocking they didn't have fucking
tickets they didn't have like 13 seconds
people were gonna look back at us and be
like all those ladies and they're clean
jokes yeah they're gonna be like wow
they only talked about squirting for
like two minutes
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]